this next story is one of the funniest
things that has ever happened on this
show I believe that I have caught
extremists right winger and proud boy
founder Gavin McInnes calling into the
show pretending to be someone else in
order to promote his new program last
week I got a call during live calls from
a guy who said hey my name is Jim David
have you heard about Gavin McInnes new
show he interviews left-wingers you
should go on its show you should own him
and I didn't really think much of it the
caller said he had a subscription to
Gavin McInnes his show and then after
watching all of the videos he cancelled
it and because I'm in the media space
and I've heard of Gavin McInnes his new
show it didn't sound obviously weird to
me but after the fact I started thinking
you know the truth is nobody's really
heard of Gavin McInnes his new show
especially people on the left it is sort
of weird to imagine that a left winger
is gonna go and pay for a subscription
to Gavin McInnes show and over the
weekend a bunch of people on our
subreddit started posting that hey David
that sounded a lot like Gavin himself
who called you a sort of mild Canadian
accent that was Gavin and is David
playing along or is David not realizing
it so I sent it over to my manager who
knows about this show and he said yeah
it does sound a lot like Gavin McInnes
I've gone back and listened to the call
again and I believe that this is Gavin
McInnes and this is hilarious for a few
different reasons but first let's listen
to part of the call just so everybody
knows what I'm talking about okay let's
go next to Howard caller from the
two-five three area code who's calling
today from 2 5 3 hey David it's Jim and
I just wanted to say a longtime listener
first-time caller loved ya and I just
wanted to talked about the green New
Deal and just see what ideas you had
about may begin that push through and
also a guy I despise came up on my
YouTube the other day on the commercial
this is Gavin McInnes on this new show
free speech and I was trying to click
out of it right away and then also
I saw dr. Cornel West and Mark Lamont
Hill on the show yeah and I actually
checked it out and it's a cool show in
regards to just liberals nailing Gavin
and it was so awesome watch especially
Marc Lamont Hill I cancelled my
subscription because I saw all the shows
but I just thought it'd be awesome if
you could get on his show and destroy
him so hold your subscription to what oh
I signed up just to watch the dr. Lamott
Hill oh I see any Cornel West Show so
clearly the caller is someone who's very
comfortable on calls like this that's
not really evidence that it's Gavin
McInnes he does seem to know a little
bit too much about Gavin McInnes new
show despite the fact that like no
leftist has even mentioned this program
to me ever and no leftist really seems
to be aware of this program he claims
that he subscribed to it just to see an
interview with mark Lamont Hill which
it's sort of hard to believe that that's
what somebody would do and then I went
and listened to other interviews with
Gavin and it sounds like this is Gavin
McInnes there's a slight Canadian accent
when you listen to the pronunciation of
some words the real Gavin is Canadian I
actually was able to get in touch with
former personal friends of Gavin McInnes
and said just tell me what you think is
the caller Gavin they all said I've had
many phone conversations with Gavin
99.9% that is Gavin McInnes the name Jim
that was used matches another data point
that I was able to find related to
people associated with Gavin McInnes I
don't know how else to kind of say that
part we also back track the phone number
that this individual called from the
phone number again matches a known
location for where Gavin McInnes lived
for a long time so basically I believe
there is a 99.9% chance that Gavin
McInnes is personally calling other
programs and under the name Jim reminds
me of what was Trump's fake guy Daniel
Miller or said Trump had some name he
used to call of what when when he would
call other places about himself and
there's a few takeaways number one Gavin
McInnes truly seemed so desperate to get
attention for his show that he's sitting
around call
shows like mine when I opened the phone
lines to mention his own show that's
pathetic now second why not have someone
else call like it would be hilarious if
a hundred people from my audience
started calling conservative shows and
mentioning the David Pakman show that
would actually be really funny it would
annoy the right-wing hosts I would get
those clips I would play them but me
just calling a show and mentioning my
own name that's a lot less funny and
interesting but it also goes to show
because I'm totally clueless and I
wouldn't even recognize Gavin's voice I
actually thought maybe there is some
left winger in my audience who actually
signed up and paid for Gavin McInnes is
show to watch mark Lamont Hill which
upon any amount of inspection doesn't
sound right at all now here's the the
situation that's going on behind the
scenes this is not random what's going
on behind the scenes is that Gavin
McInnes is program I don't know where
they get the money but they are offering
to pay guests to come on now this is not
typically done we have never paid a
guest we've had what 1,500 interviews
that have done we've had like two or
three people asked for money hope we've
never paid we just never pay for guests
every time I appear on CNN Fox News I'm
never paid for those appearances ok the
Gavin McInnes program is apparently so
desperate to get people to appear on
this program that they reached out to me
through my manager and offered I'm not
gonna say how much but a lot of money
for me to appear on the program so what
took place here was not random promotion
what appears that happened is that
knowing that there is a conversation
taking place with my manager about will
David Pakman appear with Gavin McInnes
Gavin thought hey here's an idea I'll
call David as Jim and pretend to be a
leftist who really wants to see David
appear on Gavin McInnes show this is
absolutely nuts that this is going on
there are other progressive hosts who I
won't name because I don't know if
they're going public with it who have
also been approached by this program and
offered money to appear and my manager
had the hilarious idea of if the number
isn't spoof like if I could actually
call the number back and speak to Gavin
say hey Jim you called me on the David
Pakman show I just wanted to tell you I
I actually am think
appearing on that show just kidding
Gavin this is you right
why'd you call me why'd you call me live
on the air let me know what you think
absolutely stunning
bizarre and outrageous that this is
what's going on but this is where things
are apparently for Gavin McGinnis at
this point in time